well it was like summer vacation came
early for Amy Schumer and Goldie Hawn
but now we finally get to see the wild
adventure they're having on screen as we
look at the girl power heating up the
summer who was planning the the
excursions that she would take when you
had some time off really we both kind of
did it would be like she gonna vote yeah
Katy was swimming out and I shouldn't
impress her but she's like a mermaid
like just see like Kate Hudson's but
like snorkeling in front of you and then
you're asleep
I know I don't I know that's not what I
look like so it was me and my two
daughters mmm
hard to believe they've only been
friends since production began on their
new movie snatched they did some major
bonding on the set playing what else
a mother-daughter duo who's South
American vacation group horribly wrong
when they're kidnapped we really get out
of here you know we get there okay it's
Goldie's first comedy and 14 years her
last one was the banker sisters
co-starring with her pal Susan Sarandon
and none of it would have happened
without a bold move from 80 i just
approached her on a plane and I'm like I
want you to be in a movie of me saying
okay oh and you said 14 years you waited
14 years this is the one I mean this is
clearly the right one to come back into
I also haven't worked in 14 years but
not my choice there came a period Bretta
am I done is it maybe is it time to go
back I don't know I was sort of doing
this in and then I met Amy really that's
what happened we had like unbelievable
sure against smart is a whip and start
like that oh I'll go where
[Music]